on que cette carte du pays et regarder
ce petit point rouge qui en fait
représente un bateau le canada c3 est
tout de suite sur ce bateau en direct on
s'en va rejoindre notre collègue marie
laure jocelyn marie-laure d'abord ce qui
me frappe en voyant votre image bonjour
évidemment mais ce qui me frappe en
voyant votre image c'est qu'on a
l'impression que le nord c'est froid et
vous pouvez faire super bien sur le pont
en ce moment c'est parce que très peu de
connexions ici alors on pensait faire le
direct à l'intérieur et qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu on avait une meilleure
connexion corps alors hosni dehors sans
les manteaux mais c'est pourquoi
françois je vous assure dites moi qu'est
ce que vous faites donc sur cette
expédition ces trois dans le nord du
pays a continué ces concepts cette
aventure là alors cette expédition en
fait ça a été fait par le fondateur
sudan sunrise et s'appelle jesse et
c'est donc un explorateur lui il aime
vraiment grand nord et il avait envie
pour le 150e du canada de faire
découvrir de toronto à victoria pendant
150 jours et bien tout le canada les
communautés la nature les sciences et la
glace bien sûr à de nombreux canadiens
il ya eu 5000 applications 300 personnes
qui ont été sélectionnés pour venir ici
et donc qui chaque à peu près dix jours
chaque étape change donc le bateau c'est
en parfaite ul roulement et des
personnes donc qui viennent découvrir
des parties du monde qu'on n'a jamais
découvert et moi c'est ce que ce que je
viens voir et je prends aussi cette
excuse du bateau pour rencontrer des
communautés assez isolé là on s'en va
vers qui tarde joie car on va aller
jusqu'au fond il est vraiment à l'entrée
d'une bataille du nord-ouest et donc
vous êtes allé notamment à ical whitcomb
connais un peu plus mais encore là mais
j'étais surpris à quel point dans votre
article paru hier
c'est une ville multiculturelle n'est ce
pas
effectivement moi c'est ce qui m'a
frappé dès mon arrivée en fait et à
l'aéroport déjà dans l'avion est il qu'à
8 énormément changé c'est ce que les
gens là bas m'ont dit c'est devenu la
scène multiculturelle depuis que le
territoire de nunavut est venu un
territoire en 99 il cale but donc la
capitale et bien sûr ça a attiré
beaucoup de personnes qui venu pour
l'argent là on ne peut pas le cacher
beaucoup de monde me dit mais aussi des
gens qui sont venus pour l'aventurier
rencontrer une femme des philippines
puis quant à l'avenir au canada on lui a
parlé du nunavut est s'est dit mais je
connais pas ok c'est là que je vais et
puis c'est laquelle il en fait depuis
une vingtaine d'années et il ya aussi le
premier musulman qui est venu aussi ici
dans les années 90 et rigoler il dit on
est passé de 1 à 100 dans la communauté
donc il est vraiment content quand même
de voir son petit que tu réalises mais
c'est des gens qui se tiennent beaucoup
qui sont qui disent que les locaux d ont
beaucoup accueilli nunavut on est une
petite ou de se dire notre terre puis
c'est vraiment ce qu'ils ressentent
dites moi évidemment on veut pas passer
sous silence la présence des ours
polaires parce que vous en avez vu la
chanceuse très chanceuse hier matin on
s'est réveillé déjà on s'est réveillé en
fait vous réveillez vous ouvrez votre
tube aux icebergs partout et c'est comme
vraiment très très magique tout le monde
là sur le bateau même des explorateurs
quand on en fait beaucoup trouvé ça
assez magique il y avait un soleil
magnifique et puis le premier le premier
groupe scolaire a été vue puis après un
deuxième un troisième
on s'approche évidemment pas très proche
peut-être prêt c'est sûr mais c'est
vraiment impressionnant surtout sur le
bateau il ya des scientifiques il ya
vraiment des gens qui ont des parcours
de vie incroyable et qu'il nous donne
justement des explications sur les ours
polaires sur les plantes sur les
poissons il ya beaucoup de science qui
vont êtres qui sont faites sur ce bateau
par exemple il ya des quelqu'un qui
prend du sonore marins pour voir un peu
dans quel état c'est en articles donc
c'est assez passionnant puis bon on ne
peut que traquer de penser hors scolaire
françois ça c'est sûr marie-laure je
vais vous remercier merci d'avoir été
avec nous et on va se laisser en
écoutant en fait un extrait qui a été
capté je crois par vous évidemment mais
c'est le comédien maxime leflaguais donc
qui était aussi à bord du navire et qui
a été le premier c'est ça à voir les
ours polaires
je vous embrasse donner des nouvelles
merci beaucoup marie là et on écoutait
extrêmement survient onze autres
officines ont fait que mes devoirs dans
son internet sud est et centre un peu
c'est de manger ça c'est la glace